wenn du als vor ihnen verbergen wollte
dann wäre das schon gründlich schief
gegangen wird wenn sie die wollten nicht
finden
die menschheit hat das weltraumwetter
schon so sehr beeinflusst hat die spuren
kaum zu übersehen sein dürfen jetzt
freigegebene geheimdaten zeigen die
veränderungen im weltraum die menschen
verursachen
das ergebnis setzt den weltraum hat die
menschheit dramatische veränderung
verursacht welche das sind jetzt den
krieg zum kleinsten fiction herzlich
willkommen
was sie jetzt freigegebenen bis heute
geheim gehaltenen daten offenbaren ist
wirklich ziemlich dramatisch so waren
die atombombentests während des kalten
krieges ursache für die entstehung eines
zusätzlichen strahlen gürtels um die
erde damals wurden auch atombomben in
400 kilometern höhe getestet ihr
feuerball aus heißem plasma verborgt die
magnetfeldlinien der erde wie ein
starker sonnensturm und erzeugten einen
künstlichen strahlen gürtel um die erde
diese strahlen gürtel blieben wochen
bestehen und einer dieser gürtel sogar
jahre verursachten rund um den globus
starke elektromagnetische stürme die die
kommunikation störten und führten zur
beschädigung und sogar zum ausfall von
satelliten die störung des magnetfeldes
führten in der folge auch zu kuriosen
phänomenen wir konnten an orten
polarlichter beobachtet werden an denen
sie normalerweise nie oder kaum zu sehen
sind wie zum beispiel im pazifik über
der insel samoa aber auch heute noch
beeinflusst die menschheit das
weltraumwetter genauer ist ist der
funkverkehr zwischen boten die radeon
signale dafür im frequenzbereich drei
bis 30 kilo erzeugen eine blase die bis
zum innen rannte van allen gürtels reich
wahrscheinlich wenn sie damit
verantwortlich diesen strahlen würfel
weiter nach außen gezogen zu haben
aus satellitenmessungen der wichtiger
jahre geht hervor dass diese funk blasen
den zähnen allen gürtel weiter nach
außen geschoben habe wenn er also jede
absicht gehabt hätten und vor allem zu
verbergen haben wir es zumindest in den
fünfziger sechziger jahren des letzten
jahrhunderts ziemlich dumm angestellt
und auch jetzt verändern wir den
weltraum nicht nur mit satelliten und
raumfahrzeugen so dass wir sofort
auffallen dürften aber vielleicht führen
diese forschungsergebnisse ja auch dazu
dass wir neue methoden entwickeln selbst
außerirdische aufzuspüren ich hasse euch
dazu hin natürlich auf dem laufenden
wenn ihr nicht verpassen wollte und mir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesse ich
mir einen auch die glocke zu geben hier
geht es weiter mit einem video zum thema
fossilien geben hinweise auf
außerirdisches leben ja sehr interessant
auf jeden fall bis dann bleib dran